[Music]
interviews are a fantastic way to
improve your English because you get to
experience the language spoken candidly
and naturally in this lesson you will
learn with interviews from the cast of
Harry Potter Daniel Radcliffe Harry Emma
Watson Hermione and Rupert Grint Ron
this is from when they were filming the
first movie let's watch the first clip
so something like want to do for ages
yeah yeah I've always wanted to be an
actress or huh I just had this really
weird thing where I couldn't say a when
I was little so I wouldn't call it a
mattress I feel that they were all
really nice and down-to-earth you could
always have a chat with them all yeah
yeah and like Robbie Coltrane Maggie
Smith then she's just gonna cut and time
you know and they're really cool yeah
Wow
my party's gone I know what that is
I said invisibility cloak I've really
wants to be nurse film so I was looking
on the Internet of this website of
Newsround
and some of these kids been selling him
videotapes themselves reading a bit of
Harry Potter
so I sent one in first I was my drama
teacher who was a woman which was kind
of freaky and dad did this rap song of
how much I wanted to be in the film sent
it in to the casting agency and then
they then I got a phone call saying um
when would you like your audition
so something like want to stay for ages
yeah yeah I've always wanted to be an
actress
you're Emma Watson is talking about
working as an actress and how she had
wanted to do that for ages the
expression for ages or in ages means for
a very long time or in a very long time
respectively I just wanted to drop these
old toys off
[Music]
so she wants to say she had wanted to
get into acting for a very long time
before working in the first Harry Potter
movie yeah I've always wanted to be an
actress so huh he's had this really
weird thing where I couldn't say eh when
I was little so I would have quit a
mattress
Emma's saying when she was little she
had difficulty pronouncing the sound ah
she probably means that she couldn't do
it to start a syllable or word as you
would say in the collocation and actress
what is interesting here is that
although the word actress also starts
with an AA sound you cannot actually
hear the AH hear but rather a na sound
always wants to be an actress
this happens because of an aspect of the
English language known as connected
speech in spoken English we tend to link
and connect different words in a way
that it would sound just like one long
word in this case when pronounced
normally as any native English speaker
would the collocation and actress
becomes an actress this is a very simple
but really great example of how to make
use of connected speech in English check
out these other examples thanks buddy
we owe Lili an apology yeah I can't
believe this this is incredible I mean
you just want an Oscar I'm sorry all the
first-class seats were taken that couple
got the last two
you see if we've gone around them like I
said wouldn't she would've given us
those tickets give it no let's try and
repeat after Emma I've always wanted to
be an actress an actress an actress so
huh least have this really weird thing
where I couldn't say a when I was system
so I wouldn't quit a mattress hey would
you like to master connected speech well
then you really should check out our
room with friends course you'll greatly
improve your pronunciation and
comprehension with these full episodes
from the first two seasons of friends
and you can try it for free right now
with our three-part mini course just
click up at the top or a town of the
description below to learn more and sign
up Arthur they were over nice and
down-to-earth you could always have a
chat with them all if you say that
somebody is down to earth you mean that
they are very practical uncomplicated
and direct in dealing with other people
that might also imply as River did here
that they are honest and even friendly
people dear Liz I hope it didn't sound
like I was trying to oversell Ted the
truth is he is a genuinely nice
down-to-earth guy and I think you two
would really hit it off
thank you awesome they were all really
nice and down-to-earth you could always
have a chat with them all so he says
that because everyone working in the
movie was so nice and accessible that it
was easy to just have a chat that is a
conversation with any of them I could
always have a chat with them all yeah
yeah and become friend Maggie Smith then
she's just gonna come up and talk about
and they're really cool yeah to go up to
somebody is to approach or get closer to
somebody all right here I go
remember how scary needs to be going up
the girls in college your hands are
shaking I know and I can't stop sweating
you just could've come up and talking
about and they're really cool yeah to be
cool as used here refers to somebody who
is relaxed or not easily upset or
worried it can also simply mean that the
person is nice so the interviewer is
asking if Rupert could just approach
anyone and talk to them since everyone
was nice to him
listen invisibility cop I've really
wanted in his film so I was looking on
the Internet of this website of
Newsround Newsround is a British news TV
show for children Rupert is saying that
he found out that the Harry Potter movie
production was looking for child actors
on news rounds website and some of these
kids been sending him videotapes
themselves reading of it Harry Potter
the videotape is a magnetic tape for
recording and reproducing visual images
and sound very popular before the 2000s
to send in or send out is a common way
to refer to simply sending mail or
objects via the mail you know every year
I say I'm gonna send out holiday cards
and I never do it you want to do want to
send this one out together and some of
these kids been sending in videotapes
themselves reading a bit Harry Potter so
sent one in first I was my drama teacher
a drama teacher educates his or her
students in different acting styles
methods and techniques for theatre TV
and film productions for example in this
famous clip from friends Joey teaches
drama at in New York College
or or let's say I want to convey that
I've just done something evil oh that
would be your basic I've got a fishhook
in my eyebrow and I like okay let's say
I've just gotten bad news but all I do
there is try and divide 232 by 13
[Applause]
and that's how it's done first I was my
drama teacher who was a woman which was
kind of freaky if someone or something
is freaky they are very unusual or
strange in some way here read this thing
oh my god so here at learn English with
TV series every single week we hope
learners to understand that speaking
natives without getting lost without
missing the jokes and without subtitles
for example she once said that now when
he travels he gets compliments on how
great his English is so if you want to
improve your English fluency just like
you all be sure that subscribe button
and the bell down below so you don't
miss a single one of our new lessons
down to this rap song of how much I
wants to be in the film sent it in to
the casting agency and then they then I
got a phone call saying I'm when we shot
your audition an audition is like an
interview for a particular role or job
typically done by actors dancers and
musicians consisting of a practical
demonstration of the candidates ability
to perform actors normally have to play
a short scene of the movie or show they
are auditioning for so they can be
judged and selected by the producers of
the film to cast an actor is to choose
or hire an actor for a specific role a
casting agency is a company that helps
film production with the process of
searching interviewing and selecting
actors or actresses Rupert is saying
that he wrote and recorded a rap song
about how much he wanted to be in the
Harry Potter movie and sent it in to the
casting agency
[Music]
what was your favorite part about making
that movie one of them is probably I'm
working with Chris Columbus yeah because
he is just he's an inspiration he's
energetic he's passionate he's kind he's
just he's fantastic my chaperone was
great my high lady was great makeup lady
was great clothes team lady was great
they're all realized just everyone yeah
yeah you know it doesn't matter who it
was whoever gave me a smile right so it
must be amazing playing harami how was
it on the set looks like the three of
you got along pretty well yeah she
planning pranks on each other not on
each other but on other people like I
claimed Robbie Buhl trains fun language
to Turkish I think it was there so I
couldn't even get to the menu let alone
try and change it it was so funny but he
has a great sense of humor so he didn't
want even my mad man I once played a
prank on a Rickman okay how would you do
this is really really scary
what do bus I was imposed as lesson I
was just doodling on the quill of a book
and I drew this rather unhandsome
picture of Alan Rickman and as I was
drawing it he was staring at it right
behind me I was so scared like neighbor
yeah let's be perfect this maze yeah
he's he's wicked and really scary scary
real life as well is he yeah
[Music]
what was your favorite part about making
a living
one of them is probably I'm working with
Chris Columbus yeah because he is just
he's an inspiration he's energetic he's
passionate he's kind he's just he's
fantastic
here you can hear Daniel compliment
director Chris Columbus with a few
different words to compliment somebody
or to give somebody a compliment is to
express your admiration for somebody if
you're an inspiration to somebody you
are so successful or so talented at
something that other people admire you
and want to be like you to be energetic
it's to be a very physically active
person full of energy
example she energetically dived into the
pool a passionate person has very strong
feelings about something or a strong
belief in something for example I'm
passionate about helping people make
learning English fun and meaningful and
to be kind is to be good helpful and
considerate of other people's feelings
maybe you are so beautiful you're so
kind you're so generous my chaperone was
great this chaperone is a person who is
hired to accompany and look after
another person or a group of people it's
very common for children - chaperones
when they have to do an activity where
their family can't be there to take care
of them such as school trips my high
lady was great makeup lady was great my
clothes team lady was great there were
just everyone I was telling the
interviewer that she liked everyone who
worked with her because they were all
really nice to her so she goes on to
include her hair lady her makeup lady
and her costume lady this is a common
informal way to refer to a professional
that specializes in a particular area
and who you normally get help from if
those were male professionals you would
call them guy
what no all my guys are here hey guys
yeah you know how I got a guy for
everything well they're all in New York
my suit guy my shoe guy my ticket guy my
club guy and I don't have a guy for
something I have a guy guy to get me a
guy so it must be amazing playing Harry
me how is it on the site
if an actor or actress plays a role or
character in a film or show he or she
performs the part of that character the
interviewer is saying that it must be
amazing to perform as Harry in the movie
how is it on the set looks like the
three of you got along pretty well yeah
if two or more people get along they
like each other and are friendly to each
other she was referring to Daniel Emma
and Rupert having a good time together
as they get to know each other well it
turns out Ben and stings son do not get
along how come apparently staying son
made fun of the fact that Ben's moms are
lesbians they don't get along then you
should smooth things over make them be
friends Phoebe you can't force kids to
be friends it looks like the three of
you got along pretty well yeah you're
planning pranks on each other to play a
prank on somebody is to do something to
somebody as a joke or trick Tammy badnik
one time while I was in gym class she
stole all my clothes and left an elf
costume in my locker I don't know if my
school is a nice place we don't really
have bullies we played pranks on each
other but it was never mean let's hear
about the prank Daniel played on robbie
coltrane
who played Hagrid in the movies I
claimed Robbie Coltrane's fun and I wish
to Turkish I think it was there so I
couldn't even get to the menu let alone
try and change it it was so funny
so because Daniel change the language on
Robbie's phone to Turkish Emma is saying
that something as simple as getting to
the menu was impossible since they
didn't understand Turkish and going into
the phone settings and changing the
language back to English would be even
more difficult or unlikely so let alone
is an expression to emphasize how
unlikely difficult to happen it would be
for something else to happen example he
would never walk again let alone play
golf
so much for letting me do this public
bathrooms freak me out I can't even pee
let alone do anything else but what's
great is you don't mind talking about it
but he has a great sense of humor so he
didn't want it in mind that huh if you
mind something it bothers you you find
it annoying if you don't mind something
you are saying it does not bother you or
you don't care about it hey man what are
you doing now you want to come see a
movie with us uh you know actually I was
gonna do some laundry
okay great holies oh here you go
you don't mind do you that would really
help me a lot
but he has a great sense of humor so he
didn't want it in my man huh Daniels
saying that because Robbie had such a
great sense of humor he wasn't annoyed
or bothered by the prank I once played a
prank on a Rickman okay how would you do
this is really really scary what do boys
I was in punished as Esther I was just
doodling on my quill in a book to doodle
is to draw something without a
particular objective or focus you might
for example doodle a picture if you were
bored in class a quill is a pen made
from a feather Rupert was using his
quill to draw on his book while playing
Ron Weasley hey are you a Harry Potter
fan then you definitely are going to
want to check out this new playlist
featuring all of our lessons with Harry
Potter just click up at the top or down
in description below to find that I was
just doodling on the quill of a book I
went to this braava unhandsome picture
of Alan Rickman handsome means that
something is pleasant looking or
beautiful especially in a masculine way
usually we do not say a man looks
beautiful we say he looks handsome in
the same way it is not common to say
that a woman looks handsome unhandsome
just means that Alan Rickman did not
look very attractive in the drawing
however while handsome is a common
practical word unhandsome is rarely used
and as I was drawing it he was staring
at it right behind me to stare at
something or somebody is to look at
something or somebody for a long time
without blinking
guys why why is that kid over there
staring at me Robin Scherbatsky right
what yes I am wow I didn't mean to stare
it's just I watch your show all the time
really there's any perfectness name hey
he's wicked and really scary scary real
life as well is he yeah wicked is a
slang expression that is especially
common in the UK it is similar to the
American awesome both mean that
something is really great
do you really have that birth the what
ska wait kid
it's something that I want to do for
ages yeah yeah I've always wanted to be
an actress or huh I used to have this
really weird thing where I couldn't say
a when I was little so I wouldn't call
it a mattress I think that they were all
really nice and down-to-earth you could
always have a chat with them all yeah
yeah and what we called friend Maggie
Smith yeah she's just gonna come up and
talk to her when they're really cool
[Music]
he's just gonna come up and talk to her
when they're really cool yeah yeah my
party's gone I know what that is
I said invisibility cloak I've really
wants to be in this film so I was
looking on the Internet of this website
of Newsround and some of these kids have
been selling in videotapes themselves
reading a bit Harry Potter so I sent one
in first I was my drama teacher who was
a woman which was kind of freaky and
died did this rap song of how much I
wanted to be in the film sent it in to
the casting agency and then they then I
got a phone call saying um when would
you like your audition what was your
favorite part about making a living one
of them is probably I'm working with
Chris Columbus yeah because he is just
he's an inspiration he's energetic he's
passionate he's kind he's just he's
fantastic
my chaperone was great my hair lady was
great makeup lady was great my costume
lady was great they're all realized just
everyone yeah yeah you know it didn't
matter who it was who ever gave me
smiling all right so it must be amazing
playing Harry me how was it on the set
he looks like the three of you got along
pretty well yeah
[Music]
looks like the three of you got along
pretty well yeah she planning pranks on
each other not on each other but on
other people like I claimed Robbie Buhl
trains fun language to Turkish I think
it was there so I couldn't even get to
the menu let alone try and change it it
was so funny but he has a great sense of
humor so he didn't want it in my matter
I once played a prank on a Rickman okay
how would you do this is really really
scary
what do boss I was in potions lesson I
was just doodling on my quill of a book
and I drew this brother unhandsome
picture of Alan Rickman and as I was
drawing it he was
[Music]
staring at it right behind me I was so
scared like neighbor yeah
there's any perfectness name yeah he's
he's wicked and really scary scary real
life as well is he yeah remember that if
you want to take your fluency to the
next level we're really excited to help
you the next step is to sign up for that
free three-part mini course you could do
that by clicking that button down below
and now it's time to go beyond the
classroom and live your English haha
yeah